welcome to the Amazon s3 bucket
demonstration where we're going to
create a new bucket and take a look at
some of the features available
so we'll start by going to the storage
and content delivery section and
clicking on s3 which will take us to the
s3 dashboard and we can see I only have
one bucket in my account which is called
database table so we're going to click
on create bucket and create a new one so
just to show you if I try and create a
bucket with just two characters in its
name it's going to give me an error and
says it needs to be at least three
characters long on the other end of the
scale if I try and make it ridiculously
long and click on create it's going to
say it must be shorter than 63
characters so that's just a quick
reminder and also you can't create a
bucket with underscores in so if I just
try and call that simply learn
underscore bucket it's going to generate
an error telling me that I can't create
it with an underscore and also if I just
create a bucket called simply then it's
going to say that this bucket name is
not available someone's already using
that in that Amazon Web Services
namespace so I have to give it a unique
name so I'm going to call this simply
learn dot demo test and I'm going to
place it in the US standard region so
let me click on create so yeah there's
our new bucket and here are the
properties to do with that bucket so we
can set the permissions at the moment me
as in the database table owner has
permission to do anything with this
bucket and we'll take a look for that in
a minute and there's the option here to
static website hosting which we
mentioned and I'm going to show you
something with that shortly then mister
logging so you can enable logging for
your bucket so you turn it on you could
select a bucket in which to put your log
files we were not going to do that now
event so we could set up an event and it
could be for a put operation and we
could prefix it with say which folder it
was going to be in or the suffix so we
could say any put operation for a JPEG
file set up an SNS
pick or and SQS queue or even a lambda
function then we're going to look at the
rest of the things here at a later
demonstration in this lesson so let's
take a look at putting some data into
our bucket so let's click on simply
learn demo test tell me it's empty so
let's upload some files and it brings up
the upload API so we're going to click
on add files and I've got four files
here on my desktop I've got the health
check HTML file that you're familiar
with from previous lessons
there's the simply learn key pair which
we use to access Windows ec2 instances
that are simply learned private key
which we use to access Linux and UNIX
instances and then there's a simply
learn logo so to upload all the size
let's click on open so now what we can
do is click on set details and we can
choose where we want to put them so we
could say the standard storage or
standard infrequent or reduced
redundancy so I'm gonna stick with
standard and we could also say whether
we want to encrypt them so we could use
the Amazon s3 master key or we could use
the key management service now we don't
need to encrypt these so let's disable
that but that's where you have that
option and then we click on set
permissions and so it's granting me full
control so I can do anything I want with
these files and I can also make
everything public I'm not going to do
that yet we can set the metadata where
you can specify common HTTP headers and
content types and things like that or
you can just tick this box and let it
figure out content types automatically
which we're going to do let me click on
start upload and on the right hand side
here we can see our files being uploaded
and they are that was pretty quick so
let's take a look at one of them let's
take a look at the simply learn logo so
I click on that and then move to the top
right and click on properties so here we
are so now it tells you some information
it tells you that this file lives in the
simply learn demo test bucket there's
the file name
havock sighs it's date who uploaded it
etc and then here there's a link which
is interesting as we talked about this
is the URL to access this file directly
so what happens if we click on this tell
me there's an error okay now why is that
it says access denied if you take a look
here and that's because it hasn't got
public permissions so we need to change
that so let's go back to our file and if
we click on the permissions option here
you can see it's just me that has access
so that add more permissions let's grant
everyone open and view permissions and
click on save now if we go back to the
other window and let's refresh there you
are so we now see that we can access
that file directly using the URL and
there's the URL there so s3 dot Amazon
AWS comm forward slash simply learned
demo test which is the name of our
bucket and then the name of the file now
if we go back to our bucket let's click
on simply learn demo test and the
properties now here is the static
website hosting which we talked about
earlier and the endpoints or it would be
this simply learned up demo test dot s3
- website - US East one which is -
region we're using dot Amazon AWS comm
so enable web site hosting I was asking
for an index document so this is the
file the default file that will open
when you go to the website so let's call
that health check HTML which is the file
we've been using in our other tests and
we can set that as the error document as
well just to just because it's the only
file we have that's suitable for this
okay I'm gonna click on save so now if I
click on the endpoint it gives us an
error we've got a 403 error and it's for
the same reason as we had one
we try to access the simply learn logo
it's because we haven't set permissions
on the health check file so let's go
back and do that so we click on the
health check file we click on
permissions we add permissions and let's
grant everyone open and view permissions
and click Save
okay so now if we go back to the other
window and let's reload that there we
are so now if we hit simply learn demo
test is free - website - US East $1
Merton - AWS calm we get to see our
health check file which is this is a
healthy web server and that concludes
the bucket demonstration